you must gather your party before
venturing forth
[Music]
hey everyone is Peter Brown reading dan
Starkey's review of pillars of eternity
two dead fire in 2015 pillars of
eternity helped usher in the second
golden age of classic computer
role-playing games but a lot of heavy
hitters followed in its wake
thus it's satisfying to see that pillars
of eternity - dead fire that only keeps
pace with its contemporaries but brings
its own vitality and character that sets
it apart from a genre that has been
feeling a bit crowded of late dead fire
is a direct sequel to pillars of
eternity but you don't need to have
played the first game as you'll get
solid recaps as well as the ability to
make some general choices that will
affect how dead fire plays that said
having a familiarity with the characters
and world greatly adds to the game's
overall appeal these folks have aged
wizened and grizzled a bit in the pirate
infested dead fire archipelago the
expansive maritime stage in which our
adventure is set one old friend has
taken to smoking a pipe for instance
growing a bit more relaxed and
observational punctuating thoughts and
commentary with topes to help process
his thoughts
hey this brings back some memories a'
for the most part character progression
and the nuts and bolts of play worked
just as they did before character
creation is deep and complex designed to
mimic the process of mapping out a
character in a tabletop RPG from there
you play a half realtime half turn-based
adventure the exploration done in the
former style and combat in the latter
[Music]
if you play just about any of the iconic
C RPGs of the last 20 years you'll be
immediately familiar with the basics and
dead fire on top of that though dead
fire blows out everything from its
predecessor there's more of anything you
can think of more options for character
setup more classes and skills more
specializations more items and more
levels you can also explore open waters
on a ship that you manage from crew to
cannon in much the same way that an
advanced players guide adds fundamental
upgrades to the way a tabletop RPG works
dead fire is bigger but also deeper that
said the real value of dead fire is how
its setting tees up new stories and
tales of exploration and adventure
the archipelago has been settled
throughout but plenty of islands still
contain ancient secrets and eldritch
horrors
moreover the rough-and-tumble atmosphere
demands sturdy defences and plenty of
able bodies to maintain your new ship
life on the seas is brutal and your
first major craft will barely have the
gear needed to survive even minor
engagements kidding at your mobile base
of operations becomes another major
focus and you'll always have to worry
when another ship comes into view he
walks in long slow strides toward a
brilliant pillar of audre far in the
distance it shines even more brightly in
the in-between than a SS your ultimate
goal is to track down EFS a god who has
possessed a stone colossus mysteriously
your spirit and life force is tied to
the god and only by chasing him to the
archipelago where your companion is able
to keep you alive you must set out and
figure out how this all happened and why
while trailing cthis this works
particularly well as a means of pacing
out the journey and developing a strong
through line of adventure so you set out
for whatever towns and islands you can
spot and build from there
at this stage curiosity is our virtue
questions and probes yield small
intimate stories and clues for tracking
down the big battle like these arcs
build out the texture of the world and
offers some of the most beautiful
moments in the game plus having extra
gear and experience can only add to your
proficiency in the main path how and
when you engage what the world is up to
you but you'll be partially limited by
the capabilities of your ship and the
information you've gathered ship combat
perhaps the single largest mechanical
addition to dead fire is very well
constructed bouts are turn-based and
will be determined by everything from
the abilities and experience of the crew
you've gathered to the tactical choices
you make these largely Center on
positioning which is important to keep
in mind when attacking
we're defending most vessels we'll have
different types of guns so you'll be
working on closing or creating distance
and repositioning so you can get the
best shots off at the right times
boarding of course also plays a huge
role but that works more or less the
same way as any other battle in dead
fire all of this feeds into systems that
impact how successful you are at general
pirating your crews morale will need to
be kept high for instance or you could
run the risk of mutiny well that could
have been little more than set-dressing
dead fire pulls those threads into the
rest of the game primarily through its
art and writing rich detailed prose
focuses on setting the scene and
building an atmosphere that fires
characters are bright and nuanced and
their descriptions weave personality
into the simplest interactions oh you
won't be regretting this washer at least
so long as you keep a Serbian grog and
lie on the onions empty [ __ ] apples
ain't never agreed with me and I'll be
suspect and they never will he's not
sleeping near my berth I promise you
that much all this makes for an
enriching read if you've got the
patience for it
like the first game the writing is
phenomenal overall but some sections can
be unnecessarily verbose and that can
occasionally strike as a weakness an
indistinct figure stands before you
flickering between forms like a fire
cast shadow a fixed haunting grin
bottomless black eyes a yawning chasm in
the earth the aspects of Bharath the
usher and the pallid night shift in and
out of focus but more often than not
vivid text is a means to help you escape
to this fantastical world thankfully
though it's not the only trek Dead fires
got while the isometric view is a bit of
a throwback the art and visual detail of
the world stands abreast with the
writing as one of the adventures
strongest points not only is this a
visual feast mostly because of the
imaginative setting and application of
the arcane but it's Direction is
poignant in gripping the seaside shacks
and exotic otherworldly creatures are a
stark departure of the classical fantasy
setting of the previous entries dire
wood the cliched stylings of
new a castle give way to Treasure Island
with all the monsters and magic of D&D
in other words this is more a fantasy
adventure in a piratey tone than the
other way around
and that works just fine keeping enough
of the original appeal intact while
folding in sharp new ideas and ambiance
dead fire is dense and it isn't a small
game easily dwarfing its predecessor in
terms of scale there's a lot to do and
it's easier than ever to get lost in the
little stories you find without
following the arcs that the game has
specially set out for you still it's
worth taking your time the richness of
dead fire takes a while to appreciate
and like the Brian sailors that call it
home you'll be left with an indelible
attachment to these islands when you do
finally step away
[Music]